hello welcome to the point the final
episode of the point of 2015 and one
that will probably look like the worst
episode because you are on camera look
no hands no steady Council yeah no it's
just well fake ultimate study thing
impossibly the echo iya stroom we could
get as well as our new studio apparently
our will room it wouldn't have been a
month or so not for the point for every
lobbying for gamespot and everything and
so because it's the final episode of the
year and also and we'll probably get to
this because we don't have much time to
make this episode right we decided to
ask I guess the viewers of the show a
bunch of questions via Twitter and and
try and talk about like the production
of the show and the ways in which it
works in the ways of which it doesn't
work like our favorite episodes have we
sort of combat publisher relations when
we're giving out a bad [__] yeah I'm
actually like super stoked yeah it is
but we never told me let me start out
like this is definitely your [__]
show like I barely I'm just scared
Andy's really humble is the first thing
I gotta learn about but not all the time
no uh you're so [__] good at cutting
down that stuff and then presenting it
in a way that's like super relatable and
you're like oh yeah like triggers all
this stuff so what I want to do help you
do the show is like take that and like
put it into practice what I'm good at
which is like editing a shooting yeah so
my role is very much just like
supporting you're like a Senate ater
yeah dream facilitator we should get to
the machine there's a lot of the stuffs
gonna get covered in the question Ricky
abara says how many people work on the
show hi it's us thanks to yeah we've had
we had one person help on what episode
this year Jake yeah use sort of a
production assistant which Justice Board
I walk yeah we had a lot of props to
drag out into the beach so we need
someone to help carry that stuff but
otherwise it's it's it's usually I write
the episodes and then you shoot them and
then we split the at us yeah like 5050
for you and you can tell which part it
is because its wake up way more TLC and
mine is just [__] footage pulled off
you too yeah thrown onto the timeline
next question is from
h sis how long does it take to make the
script that's a question yeah how long
does it take just click I mean this one
didn't take any [__] time ago okay is
this the script it's this graphical I
just got Twitter to the details baby the
show's end up being scripted to match
the amount of time i have the scripting
she had passed two episodes have been
kind of thrown together like the
alternative Game of the Year awards I
script it down to bed in five hours four
hours but you know what like I've
noticed sometimes you'll spend a long
time on a script but then and this
happens all like anybody that's ever
done anything like creative or whatever
in any fashion you know that like not
have like having lots of time doesn't
necessarily mean anything like cuz I've
seen you throw away an entire script and
start over like the day before and
that's been like a really good episode
you know like yeah so if there's
something that happens that week or like
you played a game and I got inspired
like the day after you've already
written a script the rocket league one
was that I yeah you like trash the
script and then just done another one
and it's like worked out yeah we'd
something completely different for the
rocket League One and then I paid it
much rocket late you can love that
absent to you that was so much fun yeah
except we were so worried about getting
we shot like three episodes that week
you did cuz we were like going to eat
three years old yes yes vacation but all
it that was also there was like somebody
shot like within yeah 200 yards of where
we were shooting that yes so don't get
robbed cuz the cameras were quite a lot
and it's just the two of us but I don't
think we looked at intimidating and so
one of us was dressed up with a soccer
player well I oh yeah and like in San
Francisco there's like a camera crew
they got jacked oh yeah at gunpoint at
gunpoint yeah so we're always like
nervous about walking around the streets
with our camera cuz apparently people
just jack but like a prince is the
destiny one which is one of my favorite
ones doc took like I was like for four
days from because there's so much
research involved okay yeah like I felt
that a member of Cameron that reality
check like that was a sure we have to
like we need your research I wish more
than were like us because the webisodes
that are just about like my opinion are
not super confident that the Destiny one
was like
was really good was really like
satisfied and we have that I was less
the time to do deadline that sort of
arbitrarily just decided right we're
posting at seven a.m. on friday okay so
we got to do it every two weeks so we
got to get them finished by end of day
Thursday yeah because they go live so
early on the Friday morning unless you
watch on YouTube and that stuff goes up
on the sunday and that was worked out
between me and Ryan who's our YouTube
guy because I sort of wanted to see what
the different audiences were because if
we were posting about at the same time
we were already getting a read and the
other reason for that actually is
because of reddish yeah cuz we started
to get like people posting it on or for
it / games which is like super cool I
don't go [__] I never log on because of
what happened with on gamers yeah I just
don't touch that [__] so minute people
started posting it around writer that
was like okay product so let me get so
much traffic out of that and we also get
so much really cool discussion which I
love and I guess like the reason for
wanting people to come to the website
although it seems to not matter as much
is expose ibly more valuable to people
but like I don't know like for a
pre-roll video generally like we're not
involved in the conversation we don't
know the CPM the money you get for
advertising on our site our rates are
higher than say what we get on YouTube
so it's always good to do that Eric
Ralph have you ever avoided topics to
the fear of publisher retribution or to
ask another way you feel restricted in
what topics you've recovered the two
biggest I guess cops we did this year
was the destiny one which was
essentially telling activision that
they're running a casino and the
assassin's creed one which was like I've
there's a long history of the point
[__] on you be some game so I kind
of felt bad about that one but it was
like but no like we're we kind of work
autonomously yeah there's no one telling
us what can't cover like nobody knows
what this app is this one is about no
this is going up in two days and nobody
even knows we're doing it like a Q&A and
a lot of times like our opinions you
might even differ like you yeah take a
stance on destiny or as like i saw i
agree with you like destiny is a slot
machine but like
you know your favorite slot machine yes
okay like I'm not upset about pissing
people off yeah there's not all like
that's what's it like the scariest thing
and I think this is why the two of us
work we work together so well is that
the scariest thing to me is not being
honest right that is it so what happens
is when we're going into like the
dangerous territory of oh ok we're going
to like say that this assassins creed
game is he isn't as good as some people
are saying or say that like Destiny's
like essentially doing something which
may be illegal so some steaks and when
we're saying that like the only thing
that matters to me the most is that you
prove your argument as much as possible
yeah like it's not just like some
reactive piece of like like ash video
it's not like trying to incite like Oh
controversy yeah completely yeah when
you hear the like people who watch this
I like PR teams of like gotten around
their computer like either for positive
or negative like that's like the most
satisfying yeah Jeff Kiva he visto
Brennan says when writing the show do
you try to avoid ideas that are overly
height ie gamergate oh yeah I think I
really don't like one of the things this
just kind of comes from like my own
mentality we're talking about games is
that I never wanted this show to be like
a reaction piece like I like measured
discussion I like being able to look at
the other side of the coin
like have it like even if you're not
directly talking about the devil's
advocate but like understanding why it
exists oh the amount of scripts veche
gamergate probably like i have written
over the past year and then just gotten
up doesn't it doesn't feel right it
doesn't doesn't either i haven't done a
good job of like expressing how I feel
or it's not the right time in like the
public conversation to bring it up yeah
or it's not my place to bring it like I
think anything we've ever done has has
tried to be like it's not just about how
we feel it's a bit like making sure it's
the right time I like that it adds to
the conversation or starts a
conversation I just I don't really know
if there's a big chorus of chat about
something I'm not really interested
screaming into it necessarily okay I
think so i have this vision where I want
to do a show that's like basically
documentary is about this I don't think
anyone would watch it i'll take 60
minutes watch it yeah yeah where you got
you I get the whole gamergate story you
have to do that right now you have to
give me those to do with all you get
like you can't just you can't have
raised in and talk about it you need to
like go [__] talk to like I hate like
Joey and go talk to whoever like on the
right you need to you need to like get
into that and I give up properly and so
we owe me handle on it and i'll show
that every two weeks and exactly there's
a question for you Randy to zen please
show us where you get all that music
from oh dude we got us this question
were there to go
you
here it is there's we have this website
we have a subscription to called audio
network.com go to it now audio network
now if you heard if you've ever done
production music where you just
subscribe to a thing and you get access
to all the songs like that look
royalty-free guilty free it's usually
just pure [__] audio network well this
is there is like bad songs it's full of
gems and it's concrete updated yeah
there's new music all the time it's got
these artists there's like hopping off
great kids I literally have like a
playlist on my pc oh so good good music
and you can you can actually did like if
you like some of the songs on the energy
by the night and you can buy them at the
site and use them in your own videos for
personal use and stuff like for like a
dollar ninety-nine cents and most of the
time what you do is you go to the next
mix because there's like 10 different
mixes yes so what we'll have like vocals
on it and the second one will be likable
the same mix with no vocals it'll be
like a 30 second version of that song
I'll be like a stinger and a 15 second
version yet so the automatic thing to do
is just everybody and I do this oh no
vocals like what is yes since we started
using like rap songs and [__] and like
fact that they're there we can use them
is just like it's so much fun the worst
one did you got me to watch 90 day
fiancé oh you hear that [__] that
[__] they use audio network so all
the time I just like I heard songs to
the point pop up on [__] 90 day
fiancé it's pretty good audio network
thanks but I don't know it is so good
please don't change our Terms of Service
next question this is josh kloss which
episode or episodes had the most
surprising reaction where they eps you
thought wouldn't be controversial or
vice versa you know what i think had the
bit with the strangest reaction with our
new intro yeah
and I guess it's to be expected love
always you like you know you're doing
something stupid or like awesome Marcus
and everybody's like oh come on like I
kind of think we should just Ram it down
their voice through theatre what is it
cuz we didn't really we had like a tiny
intro with the lady voice yeah which I
like threw together and then we ended up
sticking with ya and then so for the
intro for this it was like [__] it let's
just go over the boar overboard let's
make it like a straight up TV and trail
this concept like hell I don't think any
like I don't even think the concept
really was a working people realize what
it is it's all footage of [__] that's
like video games yeah but not no video
game foot is it sounds my big thing like
GTA and then like the lighthouse from
bioshock and then like Rob hands are we
having a cigarette pretended to be max
paying and there's like if you can see
is like a shitload of advil but that's a
tough fantasy yeah it goes by so fast so
now that's all you see so we just it
just crash cut to like the short version
yeah cuz it's fast and you still see
stuff but yeah we do listen so yeah and
there was something about so like it's
cool assamese spent that and the intro
to the lobby are the only two intros you
ever done
with Kirk as well Chevy I guard [__]
dirt killed it with this info he's a
German who's our Turkish graphics bro
and and he's so much fun to work with
because he takes the time pressure off
of doing graphics cuz I'm super slow and
he's so good at and I can't do Ricky you
borrow again asks do you have any kind
of a budget ? ? ? him he does is three ?
so we have a budget and that we work for
CBS and we have like access to some
really good [__] like what was the name
of the camera what kind it's ok it's not
that good it sold it right for consumer
level is pretty good it's a selling
fs100 which is like so old and then the
microphones like wireless labs cost of
these yeah okay that's that wireless
laser actually what's these guys we got
a little mic pack here yeah all right
and then the audio recording equipment
for the voiceovers office actually like
S&T it's pretty rudimentary here and but
we don't have like we don't have a
budget in terms of like for each episode
like for instance if we were going out
to like the fall that once we shoot out
on a beach like we'll get an uber there
that's it and we have a corporate card
so I put that on the corporate card oh
yeah actually we're pretty light apart
from that we don't really like use my
own lenses these are like oh yeah he's
all my lenses I use a lot of my own
stuff actually around here Franklin
Sizemore what does this show meant to
you dang heavy brah that's like that's
such a good interviewer question this is
the show I always wanted to make like
this is the show that I i just like
hearing people talk about games in a way
like the way you daydream about games
the way you like kind of go huh like I
wonder if why do I like this or like why
am I playing this a lot or like the
things that we don't usually talk about
I like games price like there's so much
games media now like when we were
growing like we're not that oh we're
like [__] I'm 32 32 I'm 30 in a
month's time like when we were growing
up you used to get a magazine and yeah
that was a month once a month and that
was all you got yeah where's now we're
just bombarded with so much stuff about
games and like majority of it is
relatively superfluous like reviews are
really cool
and like I like watching like let's
plays and live strings but like most
news is relatively superfluous so I
guess it was just a point of like making
videos which kind of like blast to
testify on like they they kind of kind
of like a time stamp on that era for me
this show is like the reason why I love
talking like it like I love doing other
stuff here at gamespot like loved in the
lobby I love working with everyone here
like this is this is what gets me up in
the morning like this show is well like
this is the passion project doesn't work
if it wasn't for the point like I don't
even know if I would still be yeah it's
like yeah this is the reason I wanted to
work here it is the reason I wanted to
work at gamespot in the San Francisco
was like half the platform to be able to
do like because that's what it feels
like is that we're so fortunate to be in
this position where we work for a big
size that you need to make the cool
thing yeah right because if you don't
then what what's the point like move
over and let someone else have a go so I
still don't think we've made the cool
like I feel that we've made something
but like we need to yeah I feel like
they're still like so much so much work
we're on the road to the cool thing trot
yeah so we're trying but but again it's
like so scary because what if what if no
one wants that cool thing because it's
so pretentious like like when we get to
the point where we think it's like
[__] great and it's just like too
much it's like uh like but I don't like
the intro like the instigation was like
that bump in the road were like no they
don't walk or like that's on the intro
my peoples important to the message I
don't know it's a learning process yeah
we're learning it means a lot but was
learning Andy what is your favorite
episode we've done in 2015 okay that's
easy for me because it was the Tony Hawk
episode okay yeah because we shot it at
e3 and then we sat on that interview
like yeah for a while but then we like
but then once the game was coming out it
was like momentum was right it's one
thing to talk about the history of Tony
Hawk right yeah because you could do a
point where you just ride it out and and
that's a good video in its own right
yeah it's cool but to me like it's more
important to get the story from the
source yeah and then to have a mix of
that where you're talking about it
you're talking about what it means you
you have from the man himself yeah gives
us great interview tells us like
straight up about all the stuff that's
and then we like talked to a
skateboarder who's like super influenced
by it and it's like okay yeah we got the
story and we presented it in this cool
way and like I think we got so much I've
never gotten as much positive feedback
yet on that episode and also it was the
most like personally satisfying him so
it was super long though and it's
probably why it only did like 30,000 on
the youtube or something and honestly
like of you know before I worked at
games about 30,000 on in video was made
yet hey aya not sorry not to yeah I
don't want to silly we don't appreciate
it or that it's not it's just in the
landscape we work in we're like some of
our episodes end up doing like the
assassin's creed one they did pretty
great like it in first three days that
like I feel like the people who watch
that don't really enjoyed that one
because I felt really emotional about
that like to me that was like a really
that was a time capsule video like that
was a video one would make for like ten
years exactly that's probably my
favorite this year as well and I think I
think I'm happy with the awateh one as
well because that was kind of like we
had a different script and then he
tragically passed away that week and
then it was kind of like there was
nothing else to talk about like you
couldn't talk about nothing else
mattered yeah but it was really
difficult because like there's a there's
a real burden in [__] doing someone's
obituary that's the only thing I've ever
that's the only thing I've ever edited
where I like I was I was crying during
yet it so like having him intro and
outro the video was like super important
that this was like the waters story so
yeah this is our filler episode for this
week but it was fun because I we've
never done this we've never actually
like in all the time we've done the show
like because we talked about the [__]
all the time and I liked retweet and
stuff but like we never actually like a
dress like people's actual questions so
and hope you guys enjoyed it thank you
so much really thanks so much to
everyone who's watched the show who's
gone back to us on Twitter and whoever
posted on reddit thank you so much like
that means a lot to us in terms of you
know making this show viable and
everyone who shares it like it's super
important to us and because it lets keep
doing it we hope you've enjoyed this
we've what you've enjoyed the show thank
you so much for watching in 2016 let us
know what you think in the comment box
below about what we should be doing and
maybe topics you'd like to cover
you like and what you don't like that's
always really good guidance for us and
we're both available on Twitter and
we're pretty much open to answering
anything so if you have any questions at
all about working in games or production
or about like what we should talk about
let us know there well thank you so much
watching a point in 2015 we'll see you
next year happy holidays and all the
best in the coming year
you